- Our activism is
continuing to evolve
in the next phase of
Where Love Is Illegal,
is enduring to leverage
our storytelling skills
so we can further
amplify the voices
of LGBTQI+ communities
around the world.
And we're doing just
that in Jamaica.
Last month we were recording
stories of survival.
So for the photo-interested
people here,
we shifted here from the 4x5",
this is now 8x10" that we use.
I just make my life
more and more difficult.
But we asked everyone to
write their own testimonies.
But we sort of also moved
up with technology as well,
and rather than
just writing them
and me photographing
their testimonies,
we asked people to read
them and I filmed them.
So in the spirit of having,
of amplifying voices,
we're gonna listen to Mo.
- Hi, my name is Monique.
I like to be called Mo.
I am an out member of the
Jamaican LGBTQ community.
Jamaicans are very
intolerant and homophobic.
Nonetheless, I live
my life fearlessly.
It takes a lot of courage
to live an openly gay life
in a place like Jamaica
where people are so violent
towards gay people.
To be honest, I'm
always on the alert,
and really on the defensive,
because when you
have a predominantly
male look like I do,
you can never tell when
you may become a target.
I'm always cognizant of that,
and ready to go in defense mode.
I really love Jamaica;
it's a beautiful place.
It's my homeland.
I just wish it were a safer
place for LGBTQ Jamaicans
to live, love, laugh, be happy,
and to be free to be who we are.
- So, given that we
are Witness Change,
and the change part is an
important part of what we do,
we know that recording these
nice stories is not enough.
And so we asked ourselves,
what more can we do, other
than just document stories?
So this next phase, also
is about working closely
with LGBTQ groups on the ground.
So we decided to do, in
addition to portraits,
we have started to do
workshops in the country
where these stories
are being recorded.
And we're working with
the communities there
with the aim that we
hope that we can have
stories start to come
from the community
and not just be
about the community.
So, furthermore, there's
more story-making, right.
And we still need to have those
stories make a difference.
So I sat with the LGBT
activists and we talked
about how can these stories
make an impact locally?
So we brainstormed about
different ideas of how
story-making can
impact on the ground
and came up with an idea.
So, many times when I was
working in Jamaica, people,
the reoccurring theme
was this conversation
about navigating safe places.
And I didn't know what
that meant at the time,
but they explained to me.
So they talk about,
there are places
that they can literally, where
they fear for their lives.
And they describe this
dangerous mob mentality
where one of two
things will happen
if they face abuse
in the street, which
is regularly, sadly.
So either they'll
have someone call out
homophobic or transphobic abuse,
and everyone will fall silent.
Or, worse, people join in and
you have this mob mentality
where things escalate and it
becomes very, very dangerous.
But what there is not, is
people standing up for them.
So there's that on one hand.
The other thing which they
complained about a lot
is that 10 years ago,
Time magazine did a story
naming Jamaica as the most
homophobic country in the world.
Ten years later, they're
still pretty pissed about it.
And so they would explain
to me that actually
there are many
allies in Jamaica.
It's just that they too
don't want to come forward
because they face
ridicule as well.
So they wanted to
create a campaign where
they could use the
stories they write
in the form of a
letter and photographs,
in order to interact
and engage allies,
and directly request
that these allies
find a pledge to
take a stand for them
when they need their help.
So we're in the very
early stages of this work,
but what I'm going to
do is share with you
one story written by Christina.
The line is rubbish, she
recorded it on her phone
from Jamaica and sent it to
us, it was very kind of her.
But what's really
interesting is that
not only is it a
request for allies,
but she's coming
out in this letter
to some of her close friends.
And listen to her,
already in her letter,
she knows what
they're going to say,
and she's already sort of
preempting the argument.
So it's interesting to hear
how she expresses that.
- [Christina] By the
time you read this,
I will have told you
that I am bisexual.
To be completely
honest, I cannot predict
how you will be responding,
or what thoughts
will be running
through your minds.
You're probably asking, why
is your friend bisexual?
What can you do to
change how I am?
Will she ever be happy?
What will everyone else think?
The first thing I
want you to know
is that I have
always been bisexual.
This is not a temporary phase
and it is not something I
ever chose or decided to be.
I've thought about it a lot,
and as best as I can remember,
I first knew I was
bisexual at age 10 or 11.
But even years earlier,
I knew I was different.
I am completely convinced
that being bisexual
is the way I was
born, and nothing you
or anyone else ever
did made be bisexual.
My natural orientation
and preference
is towards men and women, and
as for it being a choice,
my only choice, as I see
it, has been whether to be
open and honest
about my feelings,
or to continue to
deny and hide them.
Being bisexual is
simply part of who I am,
and a part I've been
longing to share with you
for quite some time.
The question of telling
you has been without doubt
the ultimate pressing
issue on my mind
for quite a few years.
I knew it was
something that would
eventually have to be done.
Of course, there was
always the possibility
that I could just
never tell you,
and keep that part of my life
permanently hidden from you.
For one, you are too close
and too important to me
for me to keep such an important
part of my life from you.
Up till now, I have by default
excluded you from
this part of my life,
but it has become
painful to keep something
so important to me
hidden from you.
I love and appreciate you,
Trishann, Krissann, Shantile,
and I want to give
you the opportunity
to share this part
of my life with me.
I would really appreciate
your continuous
love and support to
cushion the blows
and discrimination
from the wider society,
and to stand with
me and publicly say
you will support me
despite me being bisexual.
My greatest fear is to
be rejected by the people
I expect to be there for me,
so I am really hoping
that you don't.
I want you to
remember, Trishann,
Krissann, and Shantile,
that I'm the same person
today that I was yesterday.
I still want to
enjoy being with you,
only now you know a
little bit more about me.
And we now have before us
a tremendous opportunity
to become closer than
we ever have been,
a chance to share all my hopes
and aspirations for my life.
I still love you and will
always love you just the same,
and I hope you will
be there for me.
Will you be my ally?
- So here's our group in
Jamaica, and they and we
are very excited about making
this project a reality.
So despite the success
that we have had as
Where Love Is illegal in
disseminating and sharing
these voices and
amplifying voices,
one of our continuous
struggles is funding.
So this is the one and only
plug I'm going to make tonight
and that is, we need
$15,000 to make this happen,
and if anyone is feeling
particularly generous,
please let me know.
We're a registered charity, and
a 501(c)(3), tax-deductible.
We'll make good
use of your money.
So we keep moving on
with this idea that
if we can create locally
produced anti-stigma campaigns,
that's a really effective way
that we can be
using storytelling.
So next week on Wednesday,
I'll be going to Tunisia
where this work will continue.
The other thing that I
want to point out is that
most of this work that
we've been doing so far
has been in
developing countries,
and most of this work
has been done in the 75
countries where same-sex
acts are illegal.
But we are acutely aware
that the struggle goes on
in many countries around the
world, including this one.
And we are aware because
we read the news,
but also we're aware
because many of the people
who share their stories
with us, people like CJ,
are from here in this country.
So the next country after
Tunisia is, the next chapter is,
we would like to do Where
Love is Illegal USA.
There's been some really
great gains in this country,
but those gains are fragile.
And we think it's really
important that LGBTQI+ voices
continue to be heard in a
significant way in this country
so that we don't risk having
those gains disappear.
Not only that, while there are
gains, there's also massive
progress still in many,
many areas for many people.
So we think, in particular,
we want to be able
to make some strong work about
transgender people of color,
and homeless youth,
and other issues,
and other very
vulnerable groups.
So, okay, second plug:
if you're interested
in doing anything on
Where Love is Illegal
USA, let me know.
We need funding
for that as well.
So we're proud of the
work that we've done,
but we also recognize that
it's just been a beginning.
And we know it's just a
beginning because most days
we receive messages from
people around the world
sharing their experiences.
And we actually feel like
we're in a desperate rush
because we know that every day,
today, this week, last
week, and next week,
every single day, people are
dying because some consider
who they are or who they
love to be unacceptable.
Unfortunately, our intervention
was too late for B.
B died just three months after
this photograph was taken.
He wasn't executed or murdered
like many others
in his situation.
He was killed by poverty.
So you have to understand that
to be LGBT in many countries
is to be desperately poor.
It means to be thrown
out of schools and jobs,
abandoned by families,
forced to flee abuse,
and so many end up on
the margins of society.
I met B in the tin
shack that was his home
in Cape Town, South Africa.
He fled to Cape Town from Kenya.
I sat with him on
this tiny little bed
with my arm around him,
trying to comfort him
as he wept about the man
he dreamed of marrying,
a man who was now dead.
He told me about his
relationship with this man,
he told me how it was
a first-sight love.
And he told me about the
apprehension of introducing
his partner to his family.
And he told me about
running away from the mob
at his engagement party who
were intent on killing them.
And he told me about his fiance
being stabbed in the chest.
And he wept because
he was heartbroken.
And he wept because he was
too poor to pay his rent
and would be evicted any day.
And he wept because
he saw no future.
And in the end, this
lovely man died because
bigotry had made him too
poor to be able to afford
the medical care he needed.
One of his friends
informed me of his death,
and he told me that there
was nothing to remember
B by, except for his story,
and he begged that I tell it
so that we would remember B
even if it was
only a sad memory.
So here I am telling
you about B, like I do
whenever I get the chance
to talk about this work,
in the hope that his
memory will survive
and the tragic story of his life
can serve to save
the lives of others.
As sad as B's story is,
the more sad thing is that
there's thousands like B.
But that doesn't
have to be the case.
I believe that we cannot
care less for people
because they are further
away, or a different religion,
nationality, skin color,
gender, or sexuality.
With witnessing
comes responsibility,
and with privilege
comes obligation.
And none of us,
lesbian, gay, trans,
bi, intersex, straight,
none of us are free
until we are all free.
The survivors whose stories
I've shared with you tonight
told them in the hope
that people would listen
and their lives, and the lives
of people in their community,
would become more free.
For many, it was the
first time they shared.
And for many it was their
first step into activism.
D and O shared their
story because they hoped
people would hear their voices.
Before they were attacked,
they were not activists.
Appearing in this photo
was their first act to
defy those who would
deny their love.
This young Russian
couple were attacked
because they dared to walk
in the street holding hands.
They wrote their testimony,
but they wrote it
as a dialogue
between each other,
a paragraph each describing
the night as it occurred.
But something
unexpected happened.
There's this
testimony of violence
turned into a love letter.
And I'm going to read
you the end of it.
It ends with O reading
to her partner,
"After the attack, I
felt even more strongly
"how dear D is to me,
and how scary the thought
"that I could lose her.
"The worst thing that
I felt was an absolute
"inability to protect the
one I loved, or even myself.
"Yes, now I look
back on the street
"and look at every passing male
"as a possible source of danger.
"But every time now,
when I'm in the street,
"when I take her by the
hand, I do it consciously.
"It is my choice.
"D, hold my hand.
"This is my reward
for your courage."
In the course of this
social media campaign,
hundreds of thousands of
people have liked and followed.
In places like this,
forsurvivors like this,
that barely-conscious
action is like a hand
reaching out, offering
support, and a sign that says
that you're not alone.
A sign that says, I
acknowledge your courage.
It says, who you are is
natural, normal, and moral.
You deserve to be seen,
and you need to be heard.
It is in these stories that
have the silenced heard,
and the hidden seen,
that we can connect.
We can connect online,
we can connect through
brave organizations
fighting for equality,
and we can connect through here.
And it is in that connection
that there is a chance
that just maybe, maybe
there is a bit of future.
A future where no one
needs to cover their face
or change their name
or hide who they are.
A future where
everyone's story matters,
and a future where
love is never illegal.
I'm very grateful to be
given this opportunity
to talk to you tonight,
because you've helped me
to fulfill my promise to
the people whose stories
I said I would tell.
Today I act as
their intermediary.
They allowed me to photograph
them and record their words
in the hope they would be heard.
I'd like to thank
you for listening.
Thank you.
(applause)